crowded and lots of expectation rightly
so fellow leaders
excellencies distinguished friends
ladies and gentlemen it is a huge honor
for us to welcome you all here in
Brussels for the very first edition of
the global gateway
forum and to our special guests who have
come from so far I would like to express
all my thanks that you made this journey
it's wonderful to have you
here the poet and Statesman Johan Wang
F wrote in one of his great
works who who he who moves not forward
goes backward and so often gutter was
right we're here to move forward
together because in the recent years it
has often felt like the world has taken
a step step
back we know that 18 days ago a heus
attack by Hamas on
Israel has triggered even more conflict
and suffering in the
region Russia is waging an Imperial War
of aggression against its smaller
Democratic neighbor
Ukraine we are in a climate
crisis we are still recovering from a
pandemic that ravaged lives life hoods
and
trade these are great challenges that
affect us all and demand our
cooperation the fate of present and
future
Generations depends on more than
before on the quality and the quantity
of the infrastructure that connects us
all investment in affordable clean
energy investment in digital
infrastructure
investment to better equip our workers
with still skills that match the jobs of
tomorrow and that is why team Europe has
put forward Europe's largest global
investment program
ever as you know we call it global
gateway it's a 300 billion Euro program
for financing and building clean
infrastructure and global gateway has
the size to make a
difference global gateway just as
importantly lays out a new approach to
Big infrastructure projects for us it's
important that global gateway is about
giving choices to countries better
choices because for many countries
around the world investment options are
not only
limited but they all come come with a
lot of small print and sometimes with a
very high price sometimes it is the
environment that pays the
price sometimes it is workers who are
stripped of their
rights sometimes foreign workers are
brought
in and sometimes National sovereignity
is
compromised no country should be faced
with a situation in which the only
option to finance its essential
infrastructure is to sell its
future we in Europe have a clear
strategic interest to join forces at I
level to overcome Global challenges and
there are Global challenges a virus that
knows no border climate change knows no
border the same is true for the impact
of
terrorism and
War we know that our security is built
on your security and vice
versa our
competitiveness increases when your
economies grow and
prosper our resilience is stronger when
you our friends are also more
resilient then we will all
win and that's why Europe has chosen to
work closer with our
partners and two years since we have
launched global gateway we're seeing the
positive results so let me share with
you some stories of the
impact this year's Nobel Prize winner in
medicine was awarded to kataline Karo
and Drew
Weissman for their discoveries of mRNA
vaccines back in the
1990s these pioneering scientists had a
difficult time finding money for their
research we all know the stories two
decades
later their work helped to develop safe
and effective vaccines against coid 19
in record
time and it saved millions of lives
around the
world it was in this of
need that global gateway was
born because despite the success of MRN
vaccines many regions of the world did
not yet have access to the life-saving
technology so following the call from
African leaders the European commission
and team Europe got together with World
leading companies like bch and
universals and others
we teamed up with Ghana Randa Sagal
South Africa to build the first vaccine
manufacturing capacity on the
continent and to date we have already
mobilized 1.2 billion euros the modular
factories have already arrived in Ronda
to help produce mRNA
vaccines and it's not only about just
coid 19 vaccines the amazing thing about
mRNA technology is that it promises to
effectively fight illnesses that and you
know them all are endemic to Africa like
killing millions of people such as
malaria tuberculosis or
HIV vaccine
manufacturing was Global gateway's first
Flagship project but there are of course
many more this year alone
our work has focused on nearly 90
Flagship
projects for example we launched a
partnership with our friends in Latin
America and the Caribbean who also want
to team up on vaccines and
medicines in Mexico we saw key
investments from sopi to produce
influenza
vaccines in Bangladesh and Vietnam we've
launched projects on solar offshore wind
and hydrop power where over 1 billion
EUR
together we're laying Fiber Optic
internet cables under the Black Sea to
Georgia and Central
Asia and we're connecting Railways and
electricity grids in the western Balkans
mova and Ukraine to bring them closer to
our single
Market over the next 24 hours we'll have
announcement and signatures running into
hundreds of millions of
Euros so far since we launched global
gateway in
2021 the European Union has already
committed to 66 billion EUR to
transformative
projects and almost half of this are
grants that do not have to be paid
back and this is from our EU budget
alone very important on top come member
states and private Finance so there is
still much to do but we can already say
today global gateway is
delivery my second point is climate
change climate change causes tremendous
instability and suffering but it is also
an Economic Opportunity if we do it
right so we made clean
tech and clean energy
a priority of global gateway
Investments more and more developing
economies are joining the Clean Energy
race I'm very glad about this I saw this
firstand when I visited Nairobi for the
Africa climate Summit I must say I was
deeply impressed and inspired by the
confidence and the optimism of my
counterparts they said very clearly
clearly they want to LEAP frock into a
clean energy future while
industrializing and creating good jobs
for their
people they want to grow their economy
while protecting the green lungs of the
world they have huge potential to do
that renewable energy and clean hydrogen
critical raw materials Rich
biodiversity a young
Workforce so developing countries can be
a crucial part of the solution to
climate
change and we Europeans can
diversify and strengthen our supply
chains in those growing Dynamic new
markets that's why global gateway
investment Works they are demand driven
and they are a win-win for all Partners
involved today we will announc new deals
on critical raw materials with the
Democratic Republic of Congo and
Zambia together we are building the
trans African Corridor which will
connect Southern DRC and Northern Zambia
to Global markets via the port of lito
in
Angola we're also building strategic
economic corridors in southern Africa
connecting the Atlantic and the Indian
Ocean Namibia for example is set to
become a regional and Global energy
Hub so together we're teaming up with
the European Investment Bank to turn
namibia's abundant wind and solar
resources into plentyful renewable
energy it's a attractive business plan
that's so
interesting that countries from Colombia
to maania and Kazakhstan are working
with us on similar
projects on the one hand clean hydrogen
can be easily exported to other
countries and on the other hand and
crucially clean hydrogen can also fuel
new local industry in our partner
countries so just imagine clean steel
and
concrete or clean fertilizers and
chemicals
clean trains and ships the world is
asking for that so this is how we
together if we do it right and if we
work hard can become global leaders in
the clean industries of
tomorrow and this brings me to my third
point the private
sector can and must play a key role in
improving speed scale and impact of
global gateway Investments we need the
the private sector and that's why close
cooperation with business is one very
important pillar of global
gateway we are
mobilizing the financial
Firepower of Europe's leading
companies the magic is in its public
private
teamwork through public funds
then training and enabling regulation a
conducive environment for the private
sector so that we can provide the
long-term predict
predictability that private investors
need to start ambitious
projects let me give you an example for
an ambitious project like for example
the Medusa project which we are also
announcing today with Egypt here for the
very first time we're connecting the
North and the South Shores of the
Mediterranean with a high capacity fiber
optic
cable but we also need to ask ourselves
how can we do more together what have we
learned so far what do we need to
prioritize to be even faster go even
bigger and have even more
impact these are questions I would like
to discuss the next two days with with
you because you know that many of our
projects are just taking
off and you know where the challenges
are but also where the advantages are we
are determined to overcome any kind of
hurdle that is in our way we can do it
together we join forces we can move
mountains and succeed and therefore your
input and your advice is so important
for us dear
friends the poem by G that I quoted at
the start of my
speech is also about profound challenges
and
changes the poem was created once in a
small German Town surrounded by the wars
of the French
Revolution but it is not a story of
Despair no it is a tale of Hope
because in the end it is a tale of
ordinary women and men from across
borders overcome their differences and
work
together they move forward not
backwards this too is our mission today
and I continue to look forward to
working more closely with all of you to
shape a better tomorrow and I thank you
for your presence here thank you very
much to be at the global gate
[Applause]
[Music]
fall